so what does it mean to be in quadratic
form well quadratic means you know it's
a second-degree expression so it's like
x squared and we're used to factoring
like if you would look at this first
example X to the 10th minus 16 if this
was x squared minus 16
we'd have no problem factoring it right
it's just a difference of two squares we
would just factor it as X plus four okay
times X minus four the only difference
here is we have X to the tenth power so
how do we factor that well it's going to
be the same idea it's going to be X to
the fifth times X to the fifth and this
is going to be plus four minus four okay
if this was X to the 20th that would be
X to the tenth and X to the tenth but
you can see it's still going to be when
you foil the inside and outside are
going to cancel it's going to be just
like factoring a difference of two
squares okay so let's look at another
example say we want to factor X to the
sixth minus X cubed minus twelve we
would know how to factor this if it was
x squared minus X minus twelve right we
just factor it we say what two numbers
multiply to negative twelve but add to
negative one that would be minus four
and plus three okay the only difference
here is it's X cubed and X to the sixth
so this is going to be X cubed minus
four and X cubed plus three you can see
when you multiply these together x cubed
times X cubed gives you X to the sixth
because when you multiply you add and
when you do the inner and the outer
products you're going to get the middle
term of negative one x cubed now if we
were to make a similar problem like
let's say this is X to the 20th minus X
to the tenth minus twelve one way to
recognize this quadratic form is you see
how this middle exponent is half of the
leading exponent give this leading terms
exponent so you're going to factor it
the same way it's going to be X to the
10th access to the ten minus four plus
three so it's always going to be this
middle exponent that's here in here so
when you
multiply you add you get 20